ATISSA BANUAZIZI: When
students give their oral exams,
they are presenting the
results of their experiment
to their faculty member, their
professor for that section,
and typically also for the TA.
And so they have an audience
of about two people.
Not very big.
And in that oral exam, they give
the presentation pretty much
straight without interruption.
Then they get a Q&A session
from the professor and the TA.
And then they may also typically
get a lot of immediate feedback
from the professor
about how well it went
and some suggestions for
how to do better next time.
In the moment, it
can be hard for them
to process all of that.
Some little time following that
they will make an appointment
with me and we will
sit down and watch
the digital video
that was produced
when they gave their talk.
And typically on
another monitor,
we will have the
actual slides that they
use to give the presentation
so we can really sync that up.
This gives them the
opportunity to look
at their video in a
more objective way.
It's not immediately
afterwards, they've
had some time to
think and process.
They have a chance to
think about the comments
of their instructor through
this new lens, of somebody
who's actually watching
their own work.
We ask them to reflect on sort
of what their experience was
in the moment.
And then we sit down
and watch the video.
And we'll typically stop and
sort of debrief a little bit
when we notice things.
And I'll ask them to talk
about what they notice
and I'll tell them
what I notice.
And then when we're
done watching the video,
we might go over some of the
individual slides in some more
detail.
And then we brainstorm
together about things
that they would want to
focus on for next time,
particular issues that
they might have had,
ways that they can
strategize about improving
that for the next
round of presentations.
So this all happens after the
first ungraded oral exam on one
of their practice experiments.
But the process of
giving the oral exams
continues throughout
the semester.
And some of them choose
to meet optionally
with me before
their presentations
if they want to do a
dry run or rehearsal.
Some of them will choose to meet
with me immediately afterwards.
But the next thing
that's actually
built into the schedule
comes much closer
to the end of the semester.
At this point, they've given
their three oral exams.
And they get to choose their
favorite one to present
for a larger audience.
And once they've made that
choice, they meet with me
and we do pretty much the same
thing, we look at the video,
we look at the slides.
Only this time, it's with
an eye towards revising it
for public consumption
and a bigger audience.